yeah and some people have gone down the  flattery route they'll say oh we love  David  flattery gets here  are we going to see a beautiful check  mating  we're gonna see it aren't we I think we  are the white king is just trapped  eternally oh he needs to are you  thinking of the one I'm thinking oh no  there's a cute one that she's oh okay  let's show this pack The Rook yeah and  uh will we see Vincent resign let's keep  an eye on the players if the bishop okay  the bishop drops just wait just move  your rook and Magnus is going to do this  now wherever the bishop goes he's going  to bring his Rook Back The Bishop's  going to move and he's going to give up  his rook and deliver checkmate with a  pawn what a finish and Vincent resigns  he knew this was coming ah he should  have shown us the chat mate but there we  go Magnus eventually takes the win  it's over another win four minus Carlsen  a long grind and and what an interesting  game so many one moves